la crise sanitaire aux états unis très
grave maintenant compte près de 280 3000
morts et plusieurs états décident de
prendre des mesures soient de
confinement même l'avocat personnel de
monsieur tu as un peu rudi giuliani
après avoir parcouru le pays sans masque
et sans distanciation et tout ce qui est
hospitalisée maintenant il est quand
même assez âgés ont rejoint donc le
docteur julien cabana neurologue à
l'hôpital général du massachusetts a
fini à l'université a revu de bonsoir
docteur kavanagh merci à nouveau d'être
avec nous la situation est vraiment
dramatique audio la situation est
vraiment dramatique aux états unis et le
docteur pham chi reste en poste et
devient conseiller de ce bail d'une qui
a fait des annonces importantes
aujourd'hui avant de parler de ces
annonces club parlez-moi de ce qui se
passe chez vous sur le terrain il ya
aussi chez vous du délestage
oui on est en train de se réorganiser
pour rouvrir des unités qu'ovide ici à
l'hôpital général du massachusetts dont
je vais sans doute retourner dès la
semaine prochaine on en 8es qu'ovide
mais vous savez le massachussetts et
aussi un état assez rural où l'offre de
soin et est assez limité dans certains
coins donc on est obligé du côté de
booster en particulier de rouvrir un
hôpital de campagne qui avait été montée
de toutes pièces au mois de mars et
qu'on pensait ne pas avoir à réutiliser
nous nous y voilà il faut leur ouvrir là
dans les jours qui viennent et les
prédictions pour le taux de mortalité
sens absolument inquiétante parlons un
instant de dénomination de monsieur bail
du président désigné le dr shargorodsky
c'est une collègue à vous qui est donc
nommé à l'appuyer d'ici là c'est des
sikhs avaient quand même fait quelques
erreurs de parcours avec avec me suis
vite fait de l'administration de femmes
oui rochelle valin ce qui est
effectivement notre chef de service
ici des maladies infectieuses c'est une
faille absolument extraordinaire qui a
exercé son talent ici depuis depuis
longtemps qu'un parcours universitaire
absolument remarquable
et qui a comme beaucoup des acteurs de
santé publique dans cette crise fait ses
armes dans la pandémie de vih/sida au
cours des années précédentes
et donc elle va reprendre le center for
disease control qui vous savez donne le
ton dans le contrôle des maladies la
prévention la santé publique
les épidémies et ce qu'on espère c'est
que joe biden va vraiment laissé à cet
institut de l'institution finalement son
prestige scientifiques non politisés qui
est basée sur la science et pas sur un
agenda politique
il en a fait une priorité en fait et le
fait qu'il garde le docteur faye chi est
ce qu'il n'ya pas là un message
important pour la reconnaissance de la
science oui absolument je crois que
c'est fondamental qui est aussi cette
jonction en temps là le combat contre la
copie depuis ce que vous avez que laure
denis fochi a été aux commandes de la
réponse mais cette coupe c'est
finalement se retrouver assez désarmés
et parfois contredit par le président
des états unis
donc je pense que c'est vraiment très
positif qu'il reste et que et que joe
biden finalement lui donne les moyens de
ce qu'il souhaite faire et le secrétaire
à la santé plus un peu plus
controversées xavière berthe chez aha
procureur général de la californie donc
un procureur plutôt que scientifique
comment vous personnellement à voyez
vous cette nomination oui je pense que
il y a plusieurs signaux là
mais je crois que finalement le
secrétaire à la santé va avoir
énormément d'obstacles juridiques pour
appliquer la politique du président
byden vous savez que le président élu
souhaite avoir un ordre de port du
masque pendant 100 jours à compter de sa
rentrée en fonction mais il va sûrement
y avoir aussi des négociations très
intense avec les différents gouverneurs
et en particulier les gouverneurs
républicains qui vont devoir donc être
en tension avec le gouvernement fédéral
et donc je pense que le fait que ce soit
un avocat n'est pas totalement étranger
à ça vous avez quand même confiance en
terminant quelques secondes que le coup
de barre va être donné le 20 janvier
avec l'investiture de joe biden ça va
être très difficile vous savez on sera
tellement avancé dans cette pandémie
il ya aussi l'enjeu du vaccin dont on a
parlé la dernière fois qu'on sait qu'on
s'est parlé
mais c'est surtout ce changement de
messages et d'unification de la
politique de santé publique qu'on attend
très bien julien cabannes as toujours un
plaisir de vous parler on apprécie
beaucoup vous prenez ces quelques
minutes à chaque fois merci beaucoup et
bon courage vous devez retourner un zoom
kobe de la semaine prochaine enfin merci
à votre soirée